australia is one of the world's largest
producers and
exporters of coal used in both steel
making
and to generate power one of its major
markets is china
but months of import delays have left
millions of tons of australian
coals stranded off china's coast and the
industry
in turmoil china's doing it for
political reasons not economic reasons
because economically it's
it's self-harm to china so it's clearly
a political stance that the the party's
taken
beijing seemingly confirmed australia
was being targeted in its state-backed
global times newspaper
saying power plants have been granted
approval to import coal
without clearance restrictions from
anyone
except australia those countries that
are available and also
are willing to export code to china
indonesia russia and mongolia
and we've seen quite a lot of
willingness for those countries to
actually expand their market in china
it will no doubt further inflame
tensions with beijing which is shutting
more australian industries
out of china in a deepening trade
dispute
over foreign interference beijing's
affairs in hong kong
and allegations about the origins of the
coronavirus
talking about coal in australia right
now is a sensitive
issue industry stakeholders have been
reluctant to comment on what's happening
with china
and australia remains without an energy
policy
as more countries set climate targets
carbon dioxide levels australia was
blocked from speaking at a recent united
nations climate summit
due to its perceived lack of action on
climate change
some experts believe now is the time to
plan for a future
of reduced use of coal and other fossil
fuels
australia's increasingly being viewed
quite rightly as an international prior
on climate action
australia needs a plan we need a plan to
get out of coal and gas
we need a plan to transition all of
those workers
or a plan in the short term to find new
trade partners
australia's coal exports to china were
worth more than 10
billion dollars last year now that's
threatened
and other industries will be wondering
if they could be next
nicola gage al jazeera sydney